There's a key technique in my solution that's very useful in computer graphics.
You could compute both the top and bottom locations in the loop for capsules.
However, a better method is to initially compute the bottom location, and then
on each iteration compute only the top position. At the end of the loop, you
then set this top position into the bottom. Now, bottom is set for the next loop
iteration. The only other clever bit of code here is the realization that the
bottom sphere needs to be on for only the first capsule in a string. After that,
I set open bottom to true, so that it's never output again for this helix. If
you want to take this exercise to the next level. Rewrite the code so that the
cylinder and sphere geometry is reused throughout the helix. Right now, no
instancing is done, so it's a memory hog. Every capsule creates its own
geometry. Another extension is to allow the art parameter to be a floating point
number so you can generate just part of the arc. If you really want to play
around try factors to have the helix become a larger and larger spiral or have
the radius vary with height as a sign curve. Me, I find once I start playing
with procedural modeling that it's hard to stop. If you make something great
consider submitting it into the 3JS library itself for inclusion as a demo. You
can use get hub to make submissions, see the additional course materials for
more information.